how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we're going to be talking about one of
our favorite subjects spider-man 3
in the mcu it appears that the title for
spider-man 3 which everybody
is just dying to know right now could
have been leaked and then
discovered by a pretty reputable source
and they also have a little bit of
information
on what the movie is about if this truly
is the title so i'm gonna break down
what this title could mean
in this video but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a scarlet witch
funko pop all you gotta do to enter
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below i'm picking a winner
on monday
so today's leak comes from the twitter
account atlanta filming
now just for some background the atlanta
filming account has provided
a lot of leaks videos and photos for a
lot of different marvel studios projects
marvel studios films a good majority of
their films
in atlanta because they have a studio
there so a lot of leaked photos and
videos that have been provided by
atlanta filming in the past have given
away
much about a lot of the films that have
been coming out and one of those films
was spider-man fight from home so this
account has provided a lot of
information about marvel movies and
recently the account tweeted a pretty
interesting tweet
it reads as follows it looks like
spider-man
is home safe though so if that's spidey
it's going to be a caper movie i guess
but won't know if that
is spidey until next week so spider-man
home safe could very well be the title
of spider-man
3 the upcoming spider-man sequel and it
could be this name for a few reasons and
i'll also explain
what a caper movie is and what the plot
of spider-man 3 could be
if it is indeed a caper movie so a caper
movie is sort of
a heist movie a crime movie where you
watch the main character do a heist or
commit some type of crime
some movies like this are ocean 11
mission impossible
and inception now home safe sticks to
the normal
home in the title of the spider-man film
we had homecoming then far from home and
now
home safe and also remember that the
titles usually have
a double meaning spider-man homecoming
had two meanings it was his homecoming
to the marvel cinematic universe and it
was also his homecoming in the film
in spider-man 5 from home spider-man was
in europe but he was also far from home
due to the fact that he didn't have tony
stark or any of the avengers's help he
just had nick fury who ended up to be
talos
and if home safe is going to be a caper
movie it could imply two different
things
one of course is that he will be on the
run he was framed for murder at the end
of spider-man far from home and the
authorities are going to be after him
and of course home safe implies that he
has to leave home and eventually clear
his name and make it back home and this
is something that we can definitely
expect from spider-man 3. we know for a
fact that he's going to be on the run
which is why a lot of people have
thought that the film title could be
run from home but home safe actually
implies that he will have a chance at
returning
and that he won't have to leave his home
forever now if this is a caper film as
it was mentioned before
home safe's double meaning could
literally mean a
safe perhaps to clear his name peter
parker
spider-man has to break into something
some facility
somebody's office to find something to
prove his innocence
that could be j jonah jameson or that
could be someone like
norman osborne what if mysterio
actually worked for norman osborne and
what if mysterio was actually the first
part of the sinister six
perhaps a character like norman osborne
could have set up this entire thing to
frame spider-man
we do know that there's a new owner of
the old avengers tower they made it a
point to show us but we don't know who
owns it or what building it's going to
be
yes everybody hopes that it's going to
be the fantastic four's building the
baxter building
however it could also be ozcorp and
perhaps this building is actually going
to mean
a lot more than we think in spider-man
3. perhaps to prove his innocence
spider-man is going to have to break
into this building and find
some proof that mysterio and other
people set him up
now for those of you who are wondering
this is not a working title for
spider-man 3. we already know that the
working title is serenity now
serenity now is the official working
title so home safe
isn't the working title the working
titles for the spider-man films are
always references to
seinfeld it was this way for spider-man
far from home and spider-man homecoming
and serenity now is a seinfeld reference
as well
that means whatever atlanta filming saw
could be the actual
title but as the account mentioned they
can confirm this
next week so in the meantime while we
wait for
confirmation what do you think about
this title and what would you think if
spider-man 3
home safe would be a caper movie where
spider-man would have to break into
something to prove his innocence let me
know what you think about this title and
this plot idea in the comments down
below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
latest mcu news and spider-man 3 news as
well
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof